why do you think now
in la there's such a high level
of camaraderie as to where like
the previous era of la music i feel like
the previous couple eras of la music it
seemed like there was a lot more
division
obviously we said we weren't gonna make
it like that everyone works together
and we said we weren't gonna make it
like that like you feel me everybody has
their own personal politics
you can't get into that right that's
comes automatically with with
just being from la but the respect right
now is high yeah for each other because
you feel me people are starting to
realize like you feel me
nobody is going to respect us as a whole
unless we respect ourselves
yeah and yeah moving together that's
what atlantis was doing so well for so
long
you gotta risk they gotta respect us as
a whole we gotta have each other back
and like you feel me we can't never put
aside game banging because that [ __ ]
real
you feel me gang banging is really real
the [ __ ] is out here gangbanging like
don't think [ __ ] not really
gangbanging cause [ __ ] is doing that
but at the same time like
not to i don't want to never make this
sound weird because i don't ever want to
disrespect nobody
but uh a lot of people would say that
the [ __ ] that's making music is not
gang banging and that's not true
because them [ __ ] is gang banging too
but
as a man first there comes a point where
you have to realize like this
opportunity out here
you know what i mean i mean everybody
moving together is stronger than
everyone being
absolutely but not just even saying just
from a personal standpoint like on game
bank
right so i'm not in all i don't have the
same policies as everybody else
right you feel me so i could go right
here go right there go do this go do
that go to that i'll be cool
you feel me but a lot of [ __ ] can't do
that but when it's time to do the music
like [ __ ] having shows and [ __ ] for
some reason [ __ ]
is respecting each other so they let
everybody else yeah i mean i always tell
everybody when rj and greedo did that
show
on stage together that was the first
versus battle
that was hard as a [ __ ] and
nothing bad happened nothing bad
happened but that was just like
to show it could happen that [ __ ] was
crazy you feel me strong happened but
the city's just live road like right now
because it's like everybody really
know each other and everybody really
like i'm really a fan of the homies like
i'm really i really like their music i
like what they doing and then i want
them to
do whatever they want to do so if
there's anything like you feel me
if you having a show where i would not
come right
why wouldn't i come here so i'm not
doing [ __ ] i'm not hating on you cause
when i have a show coming to my [ __ ] yup
yup yup and you feel me [ __ ] just cool
like
it it's harder to hate on the [ __ ] way
harder
that's true it's way harder because you
really have to
pick point pick apart what you hate
because this [ __ ] could be doing
something that this [ __ ] that you like
is doing they're doing it it's so much
easier to show love
it's easy yeah it's easy to be like oh
yeah [ __ ] and you go to sleep at night
without
just feeling like don't worry about no
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying at night
man you start hating you starting
you got it putting that energy in there
yeah [ __ ] like man
everybody running their own race like my
my success is not
based off of anybody else's success
because i don't have to be here at
all right that's real you feel me this
[ __ ]
is not like this just because it's
happening to me it wasn't supposed to
happen to me
like you feel me like i didn't like
ain't nothing written that this was
going to happen for me
nobody is uh owed anything bro nobody
you feel me and i can't and if you
trying to base your success off somebody
else's success you ain't gonna never be
happy
facts that that's the worst part about
never be happy
the rap game in general is people they
they
you know i call it pocket watching it's
like [ __ ] is too busy
watching what everyone else is doing and
then
having that psych themselves out and you
don't even be knowing what you're going
on
it makes life bro if you pay so much
attention to what somebody's doing is
maybe doing better than you it makes you
second guess what you're doing
man [ __ ] be wearing fake jewelry
they have fake clothes yeah all kind of
[ __ ] and you trying to keep up with a
[ __ ] you don't know what he got going
on
some [ __ ] don't even rap some [ __ ]
are really street [ __ ] and just got
money
some [ __ ] got good jobs some [ __ ] be
in the navy and they getting a check
every month yeah they gonna get they
check every month
something is disabled getting uh what is
what's that [ __ ] called when your
disability disability
ssr [ __ ] just getting money from
everywhere yeah yeah so why are you
worried about this [ __ ] you don't got
nothing to do
that's real you need to worry about you
get you some money
like you feel me need to be worried
about the wrong [ __ ] that's why i think
it's dope it's cause i think that that
was
maybe like a symptom of like also like
you know it's it it seems like
with like guys like yourself one take j
blast beano
ruchi everyone you know they're just
doing everyone's doing them
and and it's like it's it's with
positivity it's with
camaraderie and like nobody's like
uh well not man his [ __ ] ain't his [ __ ]
man
blasters man blast ain't [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying i'm myself
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying that's my
boy no but you i'm i'm just saying that
as an example because he
cuz blast would be the guy everyone
could look at and be like god this
motherfucker's on fire and you feel some
type of way but why would you
why that's some weirdo [ __ ] like why
would you hate on that that nigga's
some weirdo [ __ ] he's doing this thing
that doesn't mean that you're not gonna
get there
no that just means like yo be happy man
he doing his thing
absolutely like people be getting too
caught up in what everybody else says
because it don't really be
it's not it's the it's their their you
got to do this you got to do that man we
got to do a work for us
yup we got to do a work for you stick to
the game plan bro put your put your head
down and get to it i look at it like
this
i'll give you a million dollars right
now you feel me i'm gonna give a million
dogs right now
you got a million dollars now you're a
millionaire now what
now what exactly so you're gonna keep
doing everything that you've been doing
right you're gonna go live your life
also i mean with the blast conversation
the guy's been making music for
years no since it's like 08 07.
we're talking to jason castro about it
he said that he made his first song with
blasphemy
yeah like we've been making songs for
years but not just even not even talking
about blasphemy
no no but just in general what you were
saying like yeah like okay cool here's a
million dollars now what are you gonna
do yeah no but not even that is just
saying like
because i hear the conversation there's
that is a conversation they can't act
like it's not a conversation
but bro going up he doing his thing who
is to say that
next year i won't have a year like i
mean you're having a year yeah but i'm
just saying like you feel me from
what the conversations be like you know
what what people politics is and how
people
like view it like all right he having
his time
he's going up i'm proud of my god you
feel me i'm happy for him
who is to say that i won't have a time
even if it's next year it's next month
next week 10 years from now
well also i can still get to wherever i
need to be
you know every everyone wins when
someone wins like that
you know what i'm saying yeah man like
it's big for the city because now
everybody's looking at the city
exactly bro you feel me it's like
everyone's gonna win like we're like i
mean think that like you know
[ __ ] kendrick lamar you know what i mean
what happened
like you know kendrick then the whole
label was just on
cue we got to see q in the as it's the
superstar he's getting grammys
exactly you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] getting grammys this [ __ ]
real out here yeah so i just think i
think la music is in a good position man
and obviously you know you're in the
forefront of that